hallo mein Name ist Luca und ich habe
einen tiktok Account
ich bin
juhu ich bin geil
ich bin sexy ja da lade ich auf jeden
Fall komplette Scheiße hoch allerdings
soll es heute nicht um meinen
bescheuerten tiktok Account gehen
sondern um die peinlichsten tiktok
Videos da schauen wir uns heute mal ein
paar an und ich reagiere da drauf
[Musik]
also ich feier seine Bearbeitung Skills
echt übertrieben
ja
[Musik]
was machst du denn da
sorry aber das wollen wir doch nicht
ernst guckt sie euch mal an also
nichts gegen die Leute hier persönlich
ne aber das ist doch so peinlich sowas
hochzuladen ich meine warum denkt man
sich wenn man die App tiktok öffnet hey
ladet ja okay ich lade selber so eine
Scheiße hoch
oh nein
[Musik]
kein Scheiß
was ist falsch mit diesen Leuten und was
machst du da bitte oh mein Gott nein
[Musik]
nein
was
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sind echt an diese Videos die mich dazu
bewegen diese App einfach nur zu löschen
und zu melden
[Musik]
40 oder so oder 50 also überhaupt nicht
negativ finde ich gut wenn ältere Leute
sich mit sowas beschaffen
ich meine beschäftigen allerdings passt
es halt nicht so in diese Standard
tiktok gemacht da rein also klar jetzt
wenn irgendwie meine Oma WhatsApp hat so
dann ist es cool und die eine Sache aber
wenn meine Oma tiktok hätte und der
Videos hochladen würde dann hätte ich
das schon ein bisschen komisch ach du
scheiße nein nein was
nein
was ist deine Mission ist das asmr
versuchst du
dich
was willst du von mir genau
[Musik]
etwa was hat sie vergessen ihre lache
daraus zu schneiden oder was
also
ich
das finde ich aber nice also sie
versucht ja irgendwelche Tänze zu machen
so darüber sollte man sich jetzt nicht
lustig machen finde ich ein paar
Sekunden
immer oh mein Gott nein
sie macht nicht wirklich diesen
Zahnseide Tanz oder
falls euch übrigens Fragen solltet was
das hier für ein Wetter ist den ich
gerade anhabe den gibt es neu in meinem
Shop am 1.12 super-shop.de
also am 1 Dezember Launch ich ja immer
neue Klamotten in meinem Shop und dass
wir diesmal so ein bisschen nicht so
krass ausgefallen wie die letzten Male
mit Jeansjacke und reflective Jacke oder
so sondern eher so basic also hier
wirklich ein gemütlicher schwarzer
Sweater hier mit so einem Bund
zerlaufenem Smiley dran heute noch mehr
Produkte sehen wollt die am 1.12 in den
luca-shop.de kommen werden dann schaut
gerne bei meinem Instagram vorbei ich
heiße laserluca und ich habe da so eine
Highlight Story wo ihr schon ein paar
mehr Produkte sehen könnt halt's Maul
was
ist falsch mit solchen
[Musik]
in diesem Video stelle ich so einige
Dinge ein erwachsener Mann in
irgendwelchen Herzchen
Schlafanzug Hosen steht in einem Jungs
Kinderzimmer wo im Hintergrund
Stofftiere sind und Auto Poster und er
hat einen komischen stofftierhut auf und
tanzt zu einem trap Song das sind 40
Millionen Gründe warum dieses Video
komplett Grinch ist also ich bin ganz
ehrlich jeder sollte auf tiktok die
Möglichkeit haben hochzuladen was er
möchte aber bei sowas würde ich mir echt
zweimal Gedanken machen ob ich es
irgendwie eine gewissen Form
veröffentlichen würde allerdings kommt
er jetzt direkt schon das nächste Video
hier na
[Musik]
oh nein das ist wieder sowas komisches
wurde ein gleich beim Drop wo er sich
dann verändert nein
[Musik]
lass mich in Ruhe damit nein
schon
warum
[Musik]
die paar kleine Zunge rein
nicht schon wieder sowas jetzt hier das
nicht wahr nein wollen wir nicht sehen
nein
[Musik]
ich will das nicht mehr sehen an der
Stelle würde ich meine reaction auf
peinliche tiktok Videos jetzt auch
beenden meine Damen und Herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat und ihr wollt dass ich
in ein paar Tagen vielleicht noch mal
auf komische tiktok Videos reagiere oder
gute tiktok Videos oder keine Ahnung
dann lasst 50.000 likes da Freunde seine
hohe Zahl aber zeigt mir dass ihr das
feiert und ja ihr könnt mir ja mal gerne
ein paar tiktok User in die Kommentare
schreiben bei dem ich mal vorbeischauen
sollte und dann würde ich das Video
jetzt auch beenden
[Musik]